I do not like my grandma me well she'll
kill me to say that
welcome back to tasting our roots I'm
Vanessa and today we're in Los Angeles
hanging out with Chef Ryan from Harold
and Belle's restaurant I'm really
interested to see how chef Ryan brings
meatloaf into his menu because he does
have a more upscale style of restaurant
today we're making a traditional
southern style meatloaf it's a beef
meatloaf only truly special ingredient
is gonna be our Harold and Belle's
Creole seasoning which we make in-house
all right chef let's go down the reload
I'm gonna start with our 80/20 ground
beef if you could just start breaking
that meat up a little bit okay the first
thing we're gonna add to our ground beef
is what we call in New Orleans cooking
we call it the Trinity so he's gonna
dump that right in okay am i mixing in
right it is mix it all in there nice
baby so we're gonna put our heralding
bells real seasoning in there the secret
recipe it's got a lot of color in there
you know it's gonna have a kitten is
there any like secret ingredient that's
not so secret that you could tell me
yeah salt and pepper
it really does pack a punch in terms of
the hardiness and the amount of flavor
you can buy the seasoning at the
restaurant but you can use you know
other seasoning seasoned halls that you
find in
we're gonna add regulator garlic French
onion soup mix gonna have some dry
parsley to create some contrast in there
so that it's not this one standard color
since we're talking about tradition this
is a staple of tradition in America this
is Heinz ketchup that's gonna add
sweetness to the dish there's a very
homestyle aspect to our food you know a
lot of these dishes that you see on the
menu come directly off the dining room
table at home they are a landmark in Los
Angeles because they were one of the
first places to open up for people from
Louisiana when they migrated to the west
coast the next two items we have eggs
and we have for Floyd common right so
this is gonna be the binding agents the
glue that's gonna hold our meatloaf
together
okay I'm gonna dump the exit does that
makes it even more flakes okay sometimes
there's a lot of pressure because you're
living up to a legacy you do have a
responsibility to uphold the promise
that this brand that this restaurant has
made to him for all those years you know
they're coming here with certain
expectations that haven't met time and
time again before and it's up to us to
continue and meet and exceed those
expectations I'm just gonna take my hand
you know eyeball it I mean you can
measure if you really want to are
pushing one to the side then come over
to our grease pans flop it down kept it
as a go form so we can serve it on the
bread and it kind of mets us with the
shape of the bread what's next we just
gonna put this in the oven
yeah we're gonna take it and put it in a
350 degree oven we're gonna let it cook
for about two hours
I wasn't always working in the kitchen I
was bussing tables and serving tables at
one point there was until I really came
back and started getting my hands dirty
and working in the kitchen all the time
that I really learned we're gonna heat
up the sauce I'm kind of like
oppositional Creole sauce also known as
red gravy like marinara sauce so it's a
little thicker and harder because of the
room
we're heating up our Creole sauce
there's some minced garlic that you're
seeing in there there's some red pepper
flakes that you're probably getting a
look at also Creole food uses more
traditional French techniques okay
Cajun food is a little more raw spice to
it and these a lot of game animals so
you'll see more like deer and stuff like
that grab a couple pieces of the
meatloaf you're gonna go right on top
but though you like a lot of great beer
a little gray gravy is nice and hearty
yeah it's gonna finish it off with some
parsley flakes this is like true comfort
food how to play thick hearty meat and
potatoes but covered in sauce and gravy
is perfect Mike please
[Music]
but first I get the heat from the spices
that you won't tell me about I did not
know that like Melo's until I stopped
eating my grandma's we lo she gonna kill
me possession come here down I can thank
you so much this is awesome I'm gonna
hug you there is something about his
food that really makes me want to feel
the comforts of home out over again I'm
not gonna say that Chef Ryan's new look
was better than my grandma's I'm gonna
try to get a phone call all open so I'm
just gonna say that chef Hines we look
kind of flavor that I had to have before
a meatloaf with specially the Creole
spice seasoning
I love how chef Ryan's dishes are simple
but they're so unique the way each with
its own twist to it and you really can
feel that every single bite
[Music]